i think we're better at setting people
up and setting ourselves up oh i was oh
never mind maybe i shouldn't no i say it
i love it
so embarrassing
what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey [ __ ] this is
unwaxed
we're going shopping with sophia and
sistine salome do we just become best
friends
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwax podcast
with your favorite sister sophia and
sistine
i feel at home again i'm so happy to be
back in the studio it's been so long oh
yeah the last episode we were zoomed i
completely finished and then we were in
florida yeah zoom in florida yeah yes
yes okay well it's nice to be back it's
more organized i feel like the lighting
for me was heinous i was sitting in
mom's bathroom when i was doing it last
time that wasn't pretty this [ __ ]
complains about lighting 24 7. this
[ __ ] you're the one that buy a ring
light if you hate it so much you bring
in ring lights all the time you're the
ring light and who looks good
can i make a comment if we're going to
continue this train of roasting you two
red flags actually that i'm looking at
right now two two yes number one
i understand you love this crew neck but
you've worn it four days in a row
no no i'm not kidding you guys she's
worn it to
two dinners in public
around the house
i hope so because the first time no no
it gets better when sophia finds one
article of clothing that she just loves
she wears the [ __ ] out of it yeah and
then you buy every color so i've seen
you in the same pants sweatpants yoga
tight you know those ones that kind of
make your hips look like body adiada
yeah you know
you've been wearing those in every color
with this hoodie i bought a matching one
to match this so i walk in and her and
her boyfriend in there and i'm like i
look like i should actually be in veil
well no you look it was very princess
diana by the way you complained and you
were like i need one so i bought it for
her i liked it
until you wore it out for me and i'll
tell you what triggered me
you walked into the living room
yesterday in the same outfit that i've
seen you go out twice before and i go
sophia
it's time to switch it up a little bit
you're really on a roll i've had such a
hard morning
number two that triggers me right now
you bought this water bottle yeah it's
two liters two liters and sophia is so
dedicated to drinking two liters of
water a day yeah well okay because i
realized my new year's resolution is a
little bit vague and so i thought
you know i need to have a bit more
structure so i'm meditating journaling
and drinking two liters of water every
day no let me i've gone to the bathroom
eight times already and it's not even 10
o'clock that's part of the reason why i
won't jump on this trend i hate
knock off my computer why don't you i
hate
going to the restroom i know that sounds
really weird but i actually
just hold it until i i hold it until i'm
actually in physical pain and i have to
like waddle no like you know i look like
i'm four months pregnant yeah i just
hate it no actually i know that
she never goes to the bathroom before
long car rides and it makes me so angry
because then she's yelling in the car of
how much pain she's in and she takes it
out on everyone when it's her freaking
bladder that's the only thing that's
causing him to be a brat so we want to
move out
that's how you're just gonna announce
wait also why don't you actually share
the truth to the listeners you owe them
that
where did you find out you're gonna
start doing this 2-liter water bottle
trend a lot of these really pretty girls
on tik-tok made me insecure that i
wasn't having my life in structures so i
figured they said my life is structured
and pretty can we talk about it so i
figured i'd copy them let's break that
down those videos that these girls post
on their reels and their tick tocks look
so stunning and they're like how to be
that girl in 2022 and they wake up and
has beautiful their candles are lit when
they wake up you open up the screens and
it's a view of a city yeah their bedroom
is just stunning and they're making
their bed okay and then they're working
out and drinking water and having lemon
in it i mean it's too aesthetically
perfect
but can you imagine how hard it is to
actually make those videos nothing it's
hard i think how many tripods they have
everywhere because they're not recording
on their hand they're like holding it
they're their bodies are in every single
yeah i know i think a lot of people make
fun of content creators thinking like oh
my god it's so stupid but that's a lot
harder listen i tried to make a video i
wanted to be that girl and i was like
maybe i'll widen my range of what i'm
posting i'll do a a baking my famous
scones right and i had a ring light
above my step by step and i looked at it
and i tried to edit it together and it
was so disgusting did you see my oatmeal
video i posted on tik tok yeah that was
so weird
it was hey because i'm trying to smash a
banana holding a phone while also
stirring it like how do you make it look
like someone literally commented she
looks like she's struggling
because the camera was so shaky but you
know what else is popping up on check
out and he wrote this down but it
reminded me was you were saying getting
the ick i've seen a lot of girls doing
this as a trend i love this trend yeah
because i am like the ickiest person
ever and things trigger me with people
so easily christina i didn't want to go
on a date with a guy because his chest
hair was patchy i mean if anyone has the
dumbest thing to get rid of a guy is
that ick or picky that's ick okay well i
was actually talking about this with a
group of friends yeah i said group
friends you guys i'm expanding there's
more than one i'm expanding and we were
talking about girls and guys things that
just give them the ick and some of them
were so funny like one person said
watching a guy
put on socks that are the no-show socks
but not wearing the no-show socks but
the act of watching him put it on
what do you think about that the act of
him putting on the no-show song yeah
they just look cringy yeah that looks
kind of weird how about shazaming a song
in the club
or ick how about this or
when when you do a baby voice and they
mimic it
oh
god god god i can't i was like you can't
do it like you can't copy the same thing
i'm doing it just we always say too when
a guy
is trying to respond to say if he posted
a really hot photo and he responds with
the exploding hat emoji
i got one recently and i literally just
i couldn't
no i just want to block you off i wanted
to send the emoji with like a surgical
mask on like i'm sick yeah get away from
me or when they spell they are as
t-h-e-i-r
go back to school when a guy asked for
your snapchat and not your phone number
that's just
that's just really sketchy that is
sketchy do you remember
creepy hen chef yeah
this man was like 28 asking for my
snapchat
i was dumb enough to give it and i i got
unwarranted selfies all day long all the
time that's it when a guy sends a selfie
with hey
did i ask for that i have another one i
don't like a guy that wears too many
rings especially on their pinky
[Laughter]
oh i got one
females that have a toe ring ick
i hate that oh i thought that was gonna
be in for a second i got one no
no a couple months ago and i tried it no
one knew i just wanted to wear it just
yeah
it wasn't my fault first of all we've
already had a discussion on the show
about your toes
and that you can pick up anything with
them your toes are basically hands
and now my fingers are literally choked
she's talking about her nails they're
not good no they're horrible because
they all fell off and now i had to cut
them and now they look like nubs if you
guys been watching this episode you look
like you have megan fox's um thumbs
oh my god yeah i forgot that she had
interesting looking friends and she's
getting married now
okay we both thought this did anyone
think the engagement video was a little
weird
the sound effects were like like
chirping and birds and okay
i totally agree with that and i would
also like to say
i was there firsthand to see this
love blossom if you will i was there for
the first interaction no one knows and i
think no one cares
she told me the inside scoop and she was
there when he was like with his other
girl well the funny thing is
i was sitting outside of my trailer
trying to get noticed by machine gun
kelly
it could have been you it could have
been me but then of course megan walks
by and i was like i'm gonna go back in
my trailer i'm going also you were
dressed like a prostitute which you
thought would have helped not really no
yeah a lot of like dark circles yeah i
looked actually disgusted it's okay
let's talk about how on the last episode
you were mentioning that you got me this
beautiful christmas gift we're going to
the kings game
sitting on the ice i booked a whole
night for her i took her on a date well
we were separated for like two three
weeks i'm like this is gonna be a
reunion where we catch about anything we
like didn't tell each other anything for
these two or three weeks so we had a lot
to talk about that's true for her new
year's and my new years and
your boyfriend not my boyfriend and so
kind of
we're not getting into this sophia no i
think you owe it to the listeners my
friend is in the back she's not a stop
gabby i can't no it's not i'm not dating
anyone
but
inside you're not dating anyone in the
area okay stop oh isn't every area good
that sounds so bad because it's not
because it's true it is true it's not
true um am i denying or confirming okay
so i took sistine out to a restaurant
and we went to a king's game
we were front row on the ice yeah like
right in front of the screen where uh
you can
literally hear a hockey plug that sounds
like a gunshot when it gets hit on the
wall oh yeah i didn't realize how loud
that we were slapping the glass well at
first we weren't this is the thing when
we get there we're the only ones in
non-jersey
gear at all we're the only ones that
genuinely did not know anything about
especially if you're sitting front row
you know those are die hard fans die
hard and sophie and i literally didn't
even know how many quarters were in a
hockey not only that it was a rangers
game so if you guys know rangers new
york they're
really diehard fans yeah so you have
like two very
very popular teams playing against i had
so many accents in my ears the whole
time which i loved oh yeah yeah there
was a lot going on the kid behind us go
wagers
wayne joyce
but i'll tell you this that kid although
he was passionate his dad
was so aggressive and heckling that the
kids started heckling yeah and it got
borderline
inappropriate for a kid his age to be
heckling i don't know yeah well this guy
was like go kings the kid's like shut up
and the guy's like look at the
scoreboard kid and the guy goes well
look at the stats overall the reason why
it was the whole time there was like
this this five-year-old arguing with
this grown-ass man what happened like 45
years old and i was like is this a joke
but just because this kid is a rangers
fan and you're a kings fan yeah i mean
it got a little crazy and sophia and i
were saying look this kid's gonna grow
up to be an absolute dog on wall street
like he is that he's like a little
jordan belford in the making yeah he
definitely was a little bigger he's
going to be honest so aggressive but i
think the craziest part about it also
was when we were first there for the
first there's three periods i think
that's what it's called yes i didn't
realize that i looked it up because i
had no idea i was like oh god if this is
four i don't know how long i can stay
here
but the first it's only an hour i know
we're acting like it's like 14 hours but
everyone's standing up banging on the
glass we were frightened yeah second
third we got jerseys we got hats we're
screaming and hitting the wall and
everyone's like who are these chicks
they went from like the first period
having absolutely thinking that every
hockey player is potentially making eye
contact with them to being like heckling
the uh rangers no but you know what i
thought was kind of funny i think sophie
and i were trying to be like
those girls in the front like puck
bunnies
like a hockey [ __ ]
dressed like hockey horses we had our
hair blown out i was sucking out a
lollipop
trying so hard to be like notice me i
want to make eye contact with one of the
players the best part is that we can't
really see their faces because they're
wearing helmets and half their teeth
the only one that looked at us the
entire game was a man that had no teeth
no teeth so all in all it was a great
day i would love for you to take me out
some more i think you're my should i
call you daddy now like what are you
what is this relationship
yeah daddy works it felt really good
okay
then you are daddy i love it um you
mentioned that you had something
happening
i want to explain this really quick
because i didn't tell cysteine this
story but it was the funniest experience
i've ever had so um i had this insane
airport experience and anyone that was
traveling over the holidays knows how
insane the airport was it was like
yeah cancellations people screaming
people fighting over their seats like it
was just chaos so i'm in florida waiting
for my flight to go directly back to la
and the gate next to me was going to new
york
and so apparently i think all of the
people that were going to jfk had to
switch their flight over to the other
flight and you can just see people
running back and forth so all of the la
people are waiting outside their gate
because
um it was delayed and like the catering
service wasn't done yet i was like i
don't care about the food just get me on
the flights like 10 o'clock at night the
gate next to us it's going to new york
the lady goes
everyone this is last call for boarding
last call for boarding we are about to
close the gates and so we're all just
standing there we're waiting we're
waiting and we hear this girl screaming
going
wait don't close it and we're like oh my
god so she she gets in basically the
gates are still up and she goes yeah man
we have time just get on the flight she
goes no no wait my boyfriend's not here
he has to make it uh tommy get your ass
over here they're closing the case tommy
i know you're hungry and so we're all
like i know you're hungry she's like i'm
out of chili's to go and i gotta get my
order so we're she's standing there for
five minutes and the girl's like okay
man we actually need to close the gate
now like we're going to be late for the
what about tommy so she gets up she'll
no wait tommy screaming through the
terminal oh god it's like a movie
i'm not even done we're all like where
the hell is tommy we're all [ __ ]
everyone's invested it it gets even
worse so then the lady so she's standing
on the other side the lady starts
closing the girl the door the girl who's
like 25 years old
holding the door open going no no no my
boyfriend needs to come on tommy come on
tommy and all of us are kind of going
tommy
tommy look all of us are getting
invested and we're running she's like
wait that's him that's i think that's
him the gray hat wasn't him and they
start they actually had to pull people
off of her to get her off the gate and
go ma'am we're closing the door it's
either you're in or you're out they
close the door no
suddenly a mit we're all like oh [ __ ]
tommy tommy's gone
tommy he looks like chris pratt from um
from like parks and rec that time love
running no
babe like hitting the door and we're all
like oh no
you missed his flight it was just like
the most chaotic thing and it was like
people had to like pull him off the door
because he was like crying he's like i'm
so sorry baby's crying but i didn't mean
to miss my flight i don't know he's not
romantic i mean kind of but so he walks
away and all of us this one lady stop
she goes
are we [ __ ] punked here like it was
like it was a literally at least six
minutes straight of
chaos and we're all like
at least something crazy
to you on a flight i know but people
walked away he walked over like tommy
good job and he's like sorry guys so he
enjoyed that burrito it was great it was
worth it it was like a reuben sandwich
he just you know that was my airport
experience i thought it was hilarious i
haven't seen anything i actually just
wanted to share this because it's kind
of random but you know how sophia is the
reader and she's such a bookworm
well i started getting into some poetry
and actually saved a poem that i thought
i should read for you
and you might like and maybe the
listeners might like it i have literally
no idea what she's talking about
roses are red
violets are blue
we love shave balls how about you baby
that's right this is a manscaped
it's your line sofia we're doing it now
yes
good you guys valentine's day is coming
and we know just the gift to give that
special someone for all and any special
occasions this valentine's day it's time
to give him the gift that four million
men worldwide trust from manscaped the
leaders in the below waist grooming so
use our exclusive offer go to
manscaped.com and use code unwaxed for
20 off plus free shipping you guys i
know the holidays just went light speed
by so if you didn't give him the gift
that he was dying for make sure you give
him the right gift this time and that is
the performance package 4.0 from
manscaped let me tell you
this product he's absolutely going to
love in the package it is the lawnmower
4.0 and i'm a big fan of the lawnmower
4.0 their electric trimmer is designed
to trim the hair on the loose skin
and get this the trimmer's advanced skin
safe technology reduces cuts and nicks
on his
delicate little
parts
sistine yes it's also waterproof if you
knew that it's waterless too so he can
shave anything and everything in the
shower so you can say goodbye to those
little hairs left behind in the sink
that we all
all hate by little hairs the package
also includes the weed whacker nose and
ear hair trimmer to whack all of his
worst weeds to complete the perfect
package for his perfect package are
their liquid formulations the crop
preserver ball deodorant and the crop
reviver ball toner the deodorant helps
his boys stay cool all day and the toner
will keep him feeling his best all day
and night you guys the formulations are
cruelty free die free paraben free and
vegan all the good stuff we love
manscaped created products he's actually
going to use after valentine's day so go
to manscaped.com
for our exclusive 20 off plus free
shipping with the code unwaxed his balls
will thank you again get 20 off and free
shipping with the code unwaxed
manscape.com gift his cupid and arrow
from manscaped this valentine's day baby
ladies going to the pharmacy in person
is so 2021 you can get your birth
control online prescribed and delivered
for free with the pill club gain time
and peace of mind back with the pill
club the licensed medical team puts your
reproductive health first with access to
affordable birth control period care and
sexual wellness products with an online
subscription life is stressful enough
luckily getting birth control and sexual
wellness products can be one less thing
you have to worry about you guys with
the pill club you won't have to wait in
line for the doctor or at the pharmacy
ever again we all hate that so the pill
club just delivers the birth control
right to your door for free in discreet
packaging along with some fun self-care
gifts and goodies who doesn't want that
if you need to renew your birth control
prescription want to switch your birth
control or maybe even try it for the
first time the pill club medical team
has your back get help finding the best
option whether it's a brand you know or
not the pill club carries over 120 fda
approved brands and ships to all 50
states so most of the birth controls are
free with insurance or medicaid
otherwise prices start as low as seven
dollars a month without insurance what
more than that their licensed medical
team is just a text away to give you the
best reproductive health care advice you
guys this stuff is really important so
right now if you go to the
unwaxed the pill club is offering 10
donations to bedsider.org
for every unwaxed listener who becomes a
patient come on your donation will help
low-income individuals get access to
birth control through bedsider.org
that's
thepilclub.com
unwax to get your first birth control
care package and donate to help more
women in need of affordable birth
control remember the pill club.com
unwaxed you must use the link to make
the donation so you guys we're so
excited to have on this week's guest
this is someone we've been considering
for a while and at first it was a little
tug and pull but we got him on you know
he is someone that we've known for a
really long time we've grown up in
similar
backgrounds so i think it'll be really
exciting to sort of hear things from his
perspective because i don't think he's
had the opportunity
to sort of share his story so we're
excited to have him on the show today so
stay tuned okay you guys today we have
on friend and long-awaited guest he is a
weightlifter actor podcaster and on top
of all of that he can sell you a house
if you couldn't already tell by the
uncanny resemblance he is also arnold
schwarzenegger's son we have the
powerhouse joseph bayena
yes joseph audience
he made it yeah thank you by the way
i nailed your last name i got it yeah
yeah after asking like three times i
know well you know what
i struggle with it so thank you so much
for coming on the show today better
getting it than not i agree okay i have
so much i want to talk to you about but
let's talk about how we even first met
how long ago have this is it's been a
while since we've known you yeah well
not that long actually i feel like we
met uh while i was still in college
that's that's right yeah because we met
at your guys's christmas your
famous annual christmas party
wait i just like when you're saying
funny that i remember the girlfriend you
were dating in college i was going out
with her brother for like two seconds
okay that's crazy yeah wait i'm trying
your blonde girlfriend i want to say yes
without her name but she had a brother
but that's so crazy
and i remember when i was going out with
him and this is my freshman year i saw
he was like showing me photos of his
sister i was like wait a minute i'm like
i feel like i could familiar yeah i was
like wait a minute i know who he is and
so i just figured i'm like small world
yeah i feel like you mentioned that i
was like oh that's cool diddy oh that's
great i feel like okay so didn't animal
we haven't oh god
oh no so technically we haven't known
you for that long but i feel like you
know we have in a weird way it's kind of
like we've been in the fam for a very
long time together obviously our dads
are extremely close and and then we have
our wild holiday parties that he's the
only one down to hang out with us until
late hours of the night
you are the last one standing at those
parties okay yeah so
i was very embarrassed that last time
because let me tell you that just so
everyone knows that this is a very
family
big thing like there's yeah there's
really like older people and then
there's like us
there's like a small group of us but i
didn't start really hanging out with you
guys at the parties until like the the
last one that's which was 2019. because
i was like i didn't know anyone i was
kind of like following my dad around
right right he's like introducing me to
everyone totally i'm like oh these girls
are like really pretty oh my god i don't
know
we're running around singing kind of a
little tipsy like yeah i think but this
time i was like i was like finally chill
like uh you guys made me feel
comfortable and i was like this is a
great party and you guys are like yeah
let's do karaoke i got so drunk
like my my dad was like it was like 10
30 my dad was like all right joe like
we're i'm i'm taking off you wanna like
what are you doing i was like oh no i
got it like
he's like i got one more song i got
another song so you go you go ahead and
i didn't realize that he was my right
like i didn't sorry it was my ride so i
was like
really good i stayed i stayed with you
like we were singing karaoke everyone
left everyone i was just uh i looked up
and like everyone was gone yeah
well i remember what happened first of
all the karaoke you killed it i have
videos on my phone of you singing and no
one was good that night sophie and i
were rapping bust a move which was
embarrassing for all of us the worst
part was uh leonardo dicaprio walked in
the moment we were mid-song and walked
out he was there yes yes for two seconds
after saying i'm saying he left he
literally walks in saw us saying i doubt
that this is
it's probably together but he's like
actually left the party but
he's like this is like this is not my
party uh
you know hammer in the fact that you
really were the last one standing i
remember um all of our
uh photos that we take at the end of the
night we're all in matching pajamas and
it's the cousins and then it's joseph in
the middle
wait you have a picture with me with you
yes yes
yes and you're getting the last
family member i'll send it to you you're
like you're the non-family member in
this group which i think is just like 17
girls so i just think it's so funny oh
man i was like i was like what is going
on because i
again i was
pretty drunk i love it i love it well
they tricked me they they
they not tricked me but i fell into the
trap because you guys were like we had
done karaoke and everything you guys
were like yeah let's let's go to the bar
so we were hanging out at the bar and
you guys were talking to your
girlfriends and i'm like chiming in you
guys are like we're all laughing and
stuff and you guys are like yeah we're
going to do kamikazes and like oh god
did we on versus eve
so the guy yeah but the bartender he's
like i'm all out of shot glasses so like
i'll just serve it to you guys in these
cups oh no
i remember this
so vividly because
you i was talking to you first and then
you take it like half the shine you're
like i can't finish this and i'm like
i'll take it
so i take it and then
our conversation like disperses for some
reason and then i go to you and we're
like having another conversation
you're like oh i can't finish this
and i'm like oh yeah
i'll take it
team player
yeah
i love it i'm like let's freaking go
like you know what you're a big guy you
can handle all those extra shots oh my
god yeah but yeah when you guys were
changing to the pajama like did a
matching pajama i had no idea what you
guys were doing i was just playing pool
in your living room i'm usually pretty
good like i'm pretty good at pool and so
all of a sudden i'm missing everything
i'm like what's what's happening right
now this is so weird and i forgot who i
was playing with but he was like yeah
what's like what's up with you and i was
like don't make me feel bad but then i
lean on the on the stick and i'm like oh
oh that's why i'm a little drunk
sometimes when you take that moment and
you reflect you're like wait am i
spinning or is the room spinning it's
not when you go to the bathroom too that
you realize it's like that's the that's
that was it it was it was like that
straight up like that meme where you
like look yourself in the mirror and
you're just like
okay i need to like splash some water i
love it why i got embarrassed was
because i was literally like calling my
my uber to go home and then your dad
comes out and he's like he's like joseph
are you
that guy has no social cues he doesn't
know that that's rude to say to someone
oh my god no but i i knew what he meant
because i feel like our dads are very
similar oh yeah in that way
so blind they don't care like they don't
mean anything ill well by it but they're
just like well i apologize for getting
you so drunk
i don't regret it no not at all it was
great it was a it was a really fun time
it was i love it so i want to talk about
your physique because i'm pretty sure
your pecs walked into the room before
you did
um
and you're so you're they're dancing if
you didn't notice they're actually
dancing
through
it
let me tell you something i follow you
on instagram and your instagram is
mostly just bodybuilder poses and you
have an insane body and i can't even
imagine the dedication and the hours
that goes in to building that so what is
that like for you everybody what even
wanted you to start that fitness journey
well to start with what made me want to
start that was i was actually really
chubby in high school like really really
overweight yeah okay oh interesting
going from uh middle school to high
school that like transitioned
no one looks good in that yeah no one
looks good i had the braces and i was
really overweight but then i got into
swimming and then swimming kind of just
like made me get really cut
and i lost so much weight got down to
like
165 pounds which is like really light
for me
yeah uh it's pretty skinny but then
college gained some of it back the
freshman 15. of course per usual high
freshman
per usual classic and just sneak up on
you yeah it really does yeah the
cafeteria food is just like oh and the
drinking all that happened yeah
yes good times good great time
but then uh i don't know i i just
started lifting weights as uh again
halfway through college and started
seeing some progress and
um i was so i didn't want to go back to
my high school shape of being
chubby again right because it made me
really self-conscious i've always been
really self-conscious about my body
so that that was the main thing is like
a mixture of body dysmorphia and like
being self-conscious about my body so it
like pushed me to never go back
to being overweight going into my junior
year of college that's when i really
just like went all out like two times a
day just training like
intermittent fasting i was trying
everything right experimenting with
everything and everything because i
really believe that
everyone's body oh excuse me everyone's
body is like so different so
your body reacts to different diets and
different training i was just trying
everything out what fad did you try that
you think is complete [ __ ] and what
actually really worked for you that was
the thing is like i'm i was so anti like
fat i was so anti like fad diet i was
just like
i want to
kind of do it in a way that works for me
that makes sense for me because i was
doing meal prepping and like meal
prepping oh that's intense i was doing
meal prepping for a little bit and it
just wasn't useful to me because
i like going out to eat and i like yeah
and like yeah i would prepare all these
meals and then next thing you know i'm
like going out to dinner and then i have
a lunch and then it's just like they
have all these stacked up yeah but then
the meals go to waste yeah you know they
go bad and i'm like well this sucks like
i i hate wasting food and yeah so it
sounds like you live by like the 80 20
rule kind of like you enjoy things but
then you also oh yeah it's super like
intuitive yeah yeah if i know that i'm
gonna eat bad i'm either gonna train
really extra hard or like extra long
before
or after okay but do you ever get burnt
out because sometimes yeah i'll do that
and i'll work out six days a week and
then i just crash and i'm like i'm not
touching the gym for two weeks yeah well
how do you prevent that well it comes
with like having a reason
so i have to have like a reason when i
don't have a reason to train
then that's when i get burnt out and i
get bored and i'm like well you know
this
like what am i doing here i'm spending
so much time right in this gym for for
what like right now i'm so focused and
dedicated because i
i just did uh a film in hawaii yes and
like half of the film i'm shirtless so
i'm like i have to have to be fit i have
to be fit right well now it's funny
because like most of the most of the
things that i'm auditioning for most of
the roles that i'm landing right now
it's like
they keep adding it in there subtly it's
like
i'm reading the script and then it's
like and then he takes his shirt off and
i'm like
oh
all right
i'll do it oh my god i want them to hire
me because my body looks great they're
like okay and she should take a shirt
that's a plus but do you think does it
bother you that you get typecast as that
guy that's the the muscle man the strong
one in all the movies or you know i
could see you playing a softie in a
rom-com you know yeah well i've been
i've been going to acting classes for so
long and that's what i've been training
for to be able to do
anything to play any kind of role i
think people are a little excited
because i'm
just now breaking into the acting world
yeah and starting to do films and of
course you know people get a little
nostalgic with like
you know seeing seeing my dad and then
i'm also
fit and like have somewhat of a physique
like similar not someone else's physique
very yeah
you guys gotta look of his body we'll
put it on the show
on the screen right here we're gonna put
it right next to your face so i think
people i mean people are just excited to
see me
do that kind of stuff and i love it
anyways you know that the action the
action stuff is great i'm prepared to do
anything to do the soft rolls to do like
the really dramatic scenes like the big
breakup scenes i don't know why i'm like
those are the most am i acting class i
don't know why i'm so good at those it's
like it's like i just try on command i
can just do it
well i was gonna say because one thing
sistine and i i mean i have it too but
when it's in this industry whether it's
acting or social media whatever um you
get probably compared a lot to him and i
know that for us like we're always
feeling like this pressure to be great
especially when we get into like
auditions or any situation where we're
meeting someone and we have to execute
something well do you ever feel that
pressure like do people put assumptions
on you before you walk into the room
yeah to an extent because well i know
it's there i know people have certain
like expectations of of what they think
i'm gonna be like or you know they they
want me to do certain roles or say
certain things that that are just like
my dad's you know right
and he's like freaking interview every
time they always want me to say i'll be
back and i'm like oh yeah i'm like stop
it
hey we get yo adrian they want us to say
yo adrien all the time it's for what i
did
but did you ever do it because i did it
one time and right after i was like why
the [ __ ] would i do that yeah so
embarrassing because i sound horrible
did you ever say it not in like a
serious interview but like
when i felt like peer pressured around
friends i'm like all right i'll do it
okay oh funny yeah do you have that
pressure yeah i think i think so but i
just don't let it really get to me
because i know that i'm working so hard
and working like to do what i like to do
and following my passions so
i'm happy
i'm training really hard and i know that
i'm putting in 110 so
you know
even though there is that pressure to
maybe make something of myself like i
just know that
me being happy and me doing what i want
to do is is good enough right and that's
going to show throughout your career
because a lot of people because we are
children of famous parents they're going
to just assume that okay everything is
handed to you you didn't have to work
that hard but
you're a clear example like time will
tell like you're working hard you're
putting in the hours you're doing
everything you're supposed to be doing
and it's all going to fall into place
yeah now when i was trying to be an
actress
trying is the key word there you were
doing it sure you might work but
you know it just it wasn't my cup of tea
and uh
i always say i have a better chance of
going to the moon than becoming an actor
but
my dad always gave me really good advice
when it came to that business and
navigating it the people the auditioning
does your dad ever help you with your
auditions or does he give you advice
advice when you're on set yeah i mean
i'm sure i'm sure uh
your dad does the same thing but
i mean my my dad really just gives me
like the most generic like not generic
because it's like really good advice but
it's like oh i feel like i already knew
that what's an example like with acting
and stuff it's it's always about the
reps
yeah just practicing practicing until
you can just say it while you know i
mean everyone always comes to me is like
how do you learn all these lines i'm
like well it's through the reps and it's
like that's what my dad told me because
uh once you're able to say these lines
while
like washing dishes or like doing your
laundry or you know someone trying to
interrupt you then you can say them
whenever because you know right when
when the camera's going and you're
saying these lines
you have the the boom stick in your face
the camera's moving around it's a
different pressure uh maybe the the guy
you know your scene partner misses a
line or something and so you kind of
like have to improv or whatever a car is
passing by so they have to cut it right
there and you just have to like roll
with it you know there's nothing you can
really do about it and you've been
saying you're doing a ton of films
lately which i'm really excited to hear
about like how many films have you done
like the last year or two years yeah so
in the last year i've done
three films wow that's amazing one i'm
really excited for that's that's coming
out soon is uh the chariot which is with
john malkovich um so that'll be a fun
one that's like a
like a sci-fi thriller but one that i'm
really excited for that i'm going to be
filming next month is bunker 13 which is
like a military action oh that is so
cute it's so me and like the character
the character that i auditioned for and
and uh that they wanted me for i was
like
this is me this is so [ __ ] me
man i want to spoil it but don't say it
well you'll have to come back uh when
you're doing your press tour yes
do you have any horrible stories
uh maybe while you're on set or during
an audition because there are so many
times where i have just completely
[ __ ] the bed when it came to acting in
front of people do you have any sort of
embarrassing moments that happened to
you on set um embarrassing moments not
yet okay i'm sure it'll happen but i did
have a really bad experience uh in this
last film the experience in general was
great shooting lava in hawaii was like
that sounds awesome it was fun yeah it
was it was really a great film and i'm
super excited for that one to come out
in summer but there was one day
that was
for some reason
just so happened to be the coldest day
hawaii's ever had oh no yeah was your
shirt off on this day yes oh no no but
oh no it was we were supposed to do an
under so
some of the scenes are underwater where
i'm like
running with the rock or like free
diving
and i know how to do all those kinds of
things but we won't as one does as well
run underwater as they were saying man
of many trades obviously to continue
yeah so so we go to the beach and i'm
like in my in my swim trunks and like in
a t-shirt ready to go
i'm freezing but it's like you know
we're gonna get in the water it's not a
big deal and i'll dry off but no the
water was crazy it was like oh god it
was going nuts and like all the
professionals were like yeah not even
we'll get into this water and there were
no other beaches that were stop and so
you had to there were still so we ended
up skipping that i passed out in the car
and woke up at the next set location
right away and i thought we were gonna
go to the hotel and change oh and so you
had to like go so i was still in my
board shorts and like t-shirt like ready
ready for a beach day but it's like
windy it's raining
and i'm like i'm like freezing and then
i'm gonna get really vulnerable here i
was so
constipated from like
the that i don't know why
i don't know if it would they were
beating me
on wax on wax uh i don't know if they
were what they were feeding me but i
just like i was so bloated i had a
stomach
i had the worst stomachache
miserable cold freezing constipation oh
my gosh and then i'm waiting there
the so i get to the next set the crew is
not nowhere to be found no they're like
an hour away and so i'm like dude
sitting there oh so i'm sitting there
for like
an hour for them to get there and then
two hours for them to like set
everything up get everything ready
the mud is crazy so it's like even
longer for them to set up i woke up at
five
and then
got to this next location at like nine
waited for them to set up by 12
and i didn't have my scene until 10 p.m
oh jeez so i was just sitting there
doing waiting around oh god and i hated
that i was like
the
which i felt really bad doing this but
the director was like what's going on
man you you don't look too good i was
like i'm pissed he's like i'm pissed and
i can't [ __ ] yes sucks i'm freezing and
i'm hungry kind of yeah i get it it was
like everything came out i was just like
i was like dude this sucks like come on
we gotta we gotta go but we ended up
shooting the scene that night and
uh
i was just so focused to like get out of
there and get it and i was like everyone
better be on their [ __ ] right now like i
don't want to be an [ __ ] but we were
like i've been waiting here for 12 hours
yeah i was like i was like guys we need
to focus right now like
the cast and crew i was like guys let's
let's we're a team let's freaking do
this yeah and just get it out of the way
i don't want to be here anymore like we
all need to go like this is a terrible
location so we killed it in like the
first two scenes and there's
a really sick scene with a horse okay i
know how to ride horses as well so
everyone does shirtless on the horse yes
the director knows what he's doing as
one does
as one does so i had a recommendation
i'm gonna spoil this scene but whatever
whatever because it's sick i'm so stoked
about it
i'm riding this horse shirtless
all damaged up and
like about to pass out and the girl that
i'm like saving yeah is like she's like
oh my my name in the film is alex she's
like alex
and i like snap out of it and i i pick
her up and
put her on the horse but with one hand
with one arm
it was my idea and they were like can
you do it and i was like oh yeah oh i
can do it and i did it first try i was
like
what if you couldn't do it
well that was the best
oh the horse was so agitated he was so
tired like he was yeah he's like i'm
tired of this guy bringing more bodies
on my back well not just that he was
just tired of wait he was waiting as
long as i didn't wait as well the horse
is a paid actor yes the horse is not
getting his uh yeah the horse needs a
raise yeah he does need a raise i agree
with him he wasn't he was in union
he's not sad he's not saying oh yeah
wait but that's badass okay it was cool
and like i surprised myself i was like
how was i how did i do this i'm telling
you right now if you clip that and put
it on like your tinder profile
or whatever dating app you're on
you're going to get endless dates yeah
that's true i can't do the dating apps
you can't i can't so you've never used
one i've tried them out i've tried like
yeah which ones have you used i've tried
hinge and raya ah same here those are
ours yeah it doesn't work it's no good
well it's just like we match and then i
hate the little
you know the message yeah i hate
messaging do people send you the
weirdest messages
no really like girls not like super
weird but guys are honest that's true
yeah do you have a type you swipe for no
oh man yeah you do do i feel like you do
what do you think my type is i don't
know
i remember okay so the one that i feel
like you're the girlfriend
but then you had another girl oh you're
single i'm assuming yeah okay
this is like the longest i've been
singing
like a year and a half or almost oh boo
hoo oh i know why sofia shut up no but
okay i've had three i've had three
relationships my first girlfriend was
three years and that was like from
junior year that's a long time
that i kind of remember no then
from high school okay yeah then going
into my junior year of college that's
when i started dating the girl that we
know yeah okay and then we broke up
after a year and a half and then my
third girlfriend we
also dated for a year and a half so uh
but you're oh okay it sounds like you're
very good at holding a relationship i
love relationships so your
relationship's good yeah yeah totally
okay and like i i've just been
hanging out did you have bad breakups or
easy breakups i don't think any
breakup's really easy
there was is there blocked numbers no no
well i'm blocked but oh joseph we're all
three yeah
that one was crazy because it was like
she broke up with me and then blocked my
ass and i was like what did i do oh
that's what i did one time ladies you
gotta mute them don't block them
i think she blocked me because
uh i found out a month later she went
back to her ex
and i was like ah okay that makes sense
she didn't want him to see
that's kind of
how do you feel about that yeah
i don't know if you guys know the band
laney but i was like listening to laney
like wait i love that you just poured
your your emotions into a band because i
do know is he in the background huh is
that what you're saying he's in the no
no no no that he just i just like
i listen to music like crazy yeah like i
listen to music based on like how i'm
feeling every day and so whenever i go
on a really bad date or i had a thing
with a guy that i thought was going to
work out date six it doesn't work out i
just get invested into a band that i've
never heard of and i'll listen to them
for the next two months get all emo get
so emo or dark and then i snap out of it
yeah i'll do the same thing it makes you
feel so much better i feel so good
generic stuff like they're like really
idioms so you've had music you've had a
lot of successful relationships i would
call them do you ever get nervous when
you're bringing them to introduce to
arnold because i know whenever i bring
them or sophie brings him a guide
introduced to sly
it is a complete disaster and i actually
dread it and we withhold that for as
long as we possibly can why what does he
do he's just he's so
intimidating and first of all the whole
stigma of people don't look at him like
a dad or a father or a husband they look
at him like rambo or rocky so when they
come to the door they assume he's his
character but really he's the opposite
because he's so introvert that he almost
has no social cues sometimes he's
hilarious he's funny but only when you
really know him yeah he's not good first
impression so the guys of course are so
nervous because they're like okay he's
gonna break my hand and then he doesn't
say hello and it just gets super awkward
so do you ever have awkward interactions
for on your no well i mean i've only
introduced those three girls too and how
was it it was fine and my dad's like
i mean i also have to point out that
with
my relationship with my dad it was it
took a little while for uh me and him to
get really
close and just like i can joke around
with him totally uh and talk about
anything like girls just stuff like that
yeah well because i was always i grew up
with my mom and like i was just always
nervous and like i didn't want him to
think bad of me totally and be like oh
like what the heck is this guy doing
like he's just partying all the time
right or like well you definitely are
not doing that i mean no you're the most
hard one but i think honestly a lot of
kids feel that same pressure i know that
i did too i feel like for the first 16
years of my life um i was just sort of
the daughter and i never had that
mature clique but i think because our
dads are in such an older generation
that
they
almost relate to us more easily now that
we're adults and they can talk to us
about more adult things and it's an
easier banter relationship so i think a
lot of people can relate to that
well now it's now it's like awesome
right now i'm like so close to to my dad
and we joke around about everything and
he always wants he always wants to hear
about the drama really that's why i love
it he's like tell me everything tell me
the drama oh i love you tell me about
tell me about the girls and i'm like
like does he ever give you dating advice
oh yeah oh i'm interested because sly we
say is genuinely one of the best people
to get dating advice from because he
knows the guy's brain so he'll tell us
exactly what he's thinking
yeah yeah but what would be yours let me
go back to your question really quick
the
introducing the girls to him yeah has
been
great because he's like he is outgoing
and he's just like
he's so
casual with it and just like whenever
i've introduced uh brought a girl over
for dinner or something we we've always
like dressed
like not similar
no not like super nice but okay just
dressed up a little yeah dressed up a
little bit
yeah he's like in his sweats and he's
just like he's like what are you what
are you guys dressed up for and we're
just like yeah we tried a good first
yeah they always get nervous like at the
beginning but then you know my dad just
like makes some jokes and they're the
ones yeah but every time on the first
dinner it's always been like
they're just like you know all quiet the
girls yeah they're like oh yeah you
don't have an ice burger because
whenever it's one of us bringing a guy
home like i know actually sistine's
boyfriend is meeting the family for the
first time again dreading it whoa i
know because they're they're am florida
and they've been dating for a bit and
they would have met he's she's not he's
in florida no the boyfriend's here but
the parents are influenced so they've
been dating for a bit but they haven't
had the opportunity to meet the parents
and i just
but it's what i'm saying is i just you
guys don't have an icebreaker like i
will be the icebreaker even though
there's not going to be that much of an
issue it's a breakfast my mind's the
buffer too yes like crazy if i was
sitting next to you and i was like oh my
god it's arnold i'd be so nervous as
well first impression are you kidding
right yeah you want to make a good
person like that so what's a piece of
dating advice that he gives you
man i'm trying to think of some of the
stuff that he's told me well i don't
know if i should say any of this
actually
how about this
piece
it's not that it's pc but i just don't
want to like i don't know i don't want
to like target anyone you know oh okay
got it you know what i mean like girls
yeah oh okay well i mean yeah okay back
to sly's advice the problem is you're
smart because you're saying you don't
want to
target anyone where sophia and i get so
specific with the details of our exes
that they know we're talking about them
and it will bite you in the ass so
you're smart yeah
no i've heard i've listened to a few of
your podcasts
i'm like oh
i bet if i knew this guy knew exactly
who they're talking about they'll
approach us about it and they say you
know what what the hell did your dad
really break up with me i'm like yeah he
did a little bit it was his words let's
talk you just brought a podcast and you
have a brand new podcast called opposite
ends i do so tell us about that well
opposite ends is uh yes brand new
podcast we just launched this year about
what's the date today the 12th 13th
yeah 13 days ago
um
we
basically are bringing people on to talk
about their career path kind of like
their life path and talk about how it
how they came from one end to the other
the complete opposite ends kind of just
breaking down
well let me
explain the reason why i came up with
this idea was when i graduated college
um i was getting rejected like crazy
from all these different auditions and
so
and i thought right away i was going to
get into acting right
not the case so i was like you know
feeling lost and feeling like oh i don't
have a purpose i don't i don't know what
i'm doing i don't know what's going on
with my life like i was all depressed
and like all down about it because i
didn't have
my thing and i noticed more and more of
my
peers were feeling the same way they're
like i don't like my job i don't know
what i really want to do with my life
and so i came up with this idea and hope
that i can kind of mitigate that
and have these people with different
career paths and different like life
paths
explain what they did what they learned
and kind of break it down and get into
the nitty-gritty so that
someone like
me or someone like that is just
graduating high school college or into
their next transition of life can just
listen to that and be like wow
that's really similar to what i'm going
through i want to do the same thing or
like you know he's doing what i think i
want to do but that doesn't sound like
what i thought what you thought the
process was well i always call it
proscribe blues is when you graduate
from college or high school or whatever
it is or you're changing jobs you feel
this sense of sadness because you're
like am i doing the right thing am i
behind in life am i
like i want to make it here because i
think that with social media we're
always so surrounded by everyone being
like successful and perfect
like we look at the crash she's like oh
they make a million dollars with the
post or they like and she's only what 21
years old or 22 years old right but
realistically no one ever gets to be
that like successful and famous within a
week or in a day or whatever it is and
so it's nice that you're breaking that
down and showing okay you know these
successful people didn't just get it
instantly they had a lot of different
paths my mom calls it you have to zig
zag to get to your end goal like it's
always gonna be different you're gonna
meet new people along the way so it's
it's nice that you're breaking down that
that's
idea that that's even attainable or
normal to like become that rich and
famous immediately after like you
thought yeah you're gonna get rolls
immediately but it's like not the case
like you're gonna get it takes a little
while it takes a little while like we
all need to be kind of patient
especially you have a dream guest that
you would love to have on your show
besides sophia and i of course of course
you guys uh yeah because we have a lot
of uh life experience that people want
to hear
lots of change since i was 19 to 23. so
let's just let me tell you obstacles
really uh
a dream would probably be
cristiano ronaldo oh that would be cool
because i love his story
um i love how he grew up in portugal
just i mean
not saying that i love that he grew up
like with nothing but he his story is
just so amazing how he you know
uh
he's not not wealthy at all just you
know grew up in
in portugal and kind of just made his
way up and went to sporting and then got
traded to uh manchester united and kind
of just like broke out you know and
became this
i mean the world's hottest
uh soccer player ever you know yeah uh
and
arguably the one of the best in the
world so would you ever ever i don't i
came and speak would you ever have your
dad on because we had ourselves on yeah
you totally should actually yeah it's a
great
he has a great story too he definitely
does are you kidding i mean i mean we've
known your dad as well for like a really
long time and he just has so he's very
funny too i think people don't really i
think that's why um you definitely
should have a mom because when we had
our dad on what surprised us the most
was we were so nervous because we wanted
it to be such a good interview because
we didn't want to waste his time and we
knew it was like sort of our only shot
to get it right
and we were shocked with the amount that
he was so different from than what
people have seen him online because
people didn't know he was funny or smart
or witty or likes to goof with my mom
all the time and then having you know
your dad sit across from you in sort of
the same comfortable position i think
you're going to get some incredible
nuggets out of that interview oh yeah
totally i just want to get
better
first yeah podcasting is harder than you
think right yeah totally
even the first episode that we recorded
i i listened to the first episode and
then we're gonna be releasing the next
episode on monday but
uh this last episode i was like man it
sounds
way better you know i'm not i'm not like
uh that's why we waited like we waited
until we would come on and we were going
to wait a couple more until we can get
up yeah it takes a little while to get
the traction it does
no it does you build the community and
everything and it's oh no it definitely
takes some time because it is such a
saturated market like everyone is using
podcasting so how can you stand out and
then it does take a year for people to
go okay like this is legitimate they're
not canceling the show within two days
because some people just can't do it but
you'll pick it up you just have to be
consistent but my question is how do you
actually have time
for everything
you're lifting and if you're not lifting
you're on a movie set riding a horse
shirtless and if you're not doing that
you are working on your podcast and if
you're not doing that you're selling a
house so
how do you balance it all and why did
you even get into real estate by the way
the reason i got into real estate was uh
because i needed a job i needed to like
a good fair i needed to pay my rent i
needed to pay my bills because uh after
college really um and i'm really
grateful that that my my dad helped me
get through college but
right when college was done it was just
like
you go you're on your own i was like oh
[ __ ] so yeah i needed a job and i was i
was not getting any of the acting roles
that i thought i was going to get and
like starting to
get paid so i was like i need to do
something so i started interning at a
this real estate company arya properties
which is the team that i'm on now with
the mentality that like oh i know
i'm gonna be a big movie star you know i
know i'm gonna be in the movies i know
i'm gonna do all these great things
and
real estate is like the big investment
thing that interests me right it's the
most solid it's the most like
like you you just it always you always
benefit from real estate right so
so i went in there i was like i want to
just learn as much as possible while
making some kind of income and then i
enjoyed it and was like oh i kind of i
think i can do this pretty well mm-hmm
so i got my license and and now i'm
going to
it sounds like when you said you were
going to be like a big move i feel like
are you a manifesto or like do you
visualize because it sounded like you're
like i'm going to be a big movie star
like this oh yeah well yeah i mean
i never like to call it like manifesting
because i feel like everyone's saying
that nowadays i say it all the time um
what's wrong with it no there's nothing
wrong with it there's a lot no please
don't hurt me um no there's nothing
wrong with it i just love like um having
a goal and then going for it yeah you
know whether it's like a super far goal
but with acting
i know
that my goal is to
you know be rep a reputable actor and
you know win some awards whether it's uh
i love that i like that
you know it's good to just say i feel
like i always downplay the things i want
i'm like i want it but like am i gonna
actually go but i would love to touch on
um you saying that you want to be a
reputable actor
and i saw in a recent interview that you
decided to drop schwarzenegger from your
name do you think that
like what was your decision and thought
process behind it was it because you
wanted to sort of make a name for
yourself and show that you could do it
on your own well i mean i never had the
schwarzenegger name in general because i
mean i but you could easily use it you
know especially in this acting world
right yeah i mean i think
really the the thing is that i just
haven't really focused on like changing
it i just
yeah i'm doing my own thing i haven't
really thought about it that much of
like oh i need to change my my last name
i have a last name already and i'm i'm
just like i think it's cool yeah it's
like a cool it is i'm already doing so
much and i'm already succeeding and and
you know moving forward with my with my
goals so i mean that's like the last
thing on my on my mind right now i love
it like you said like you said i'm busy
with all these different things so it's
like
uh i don't want to put another thing on
my plate with like trying to do all that
i see it 20 22 you're going to get a
girlfriend you're going to write because
you want shirtless do you want a
girlfriend
maybe he just wants a horse do you want
a wife
i can find something oh wifey how old
she's single i'm 24. he's 24. i'm
between you guys that's right 24. but
you know wife seems you're a little
young for a wife right now yeah i'm too
young for a while yeah okay unless it's
like wifey
girlfriend yeah yeah do you want a
relationship like i said i love
relationships i'm like super open to
like being in a relationship uh
it just has to be the right one yeah i
mean i don't want to
waste my time and their time and again
like i'm doing all these things so it
has to be someone that that's able to
work with me on that and relationships
are all about sacrifice and and
compromise so you know i'm willing to do
certain like i'm certain i'm willing to
compromise in certain ways
but if
my career is not
what they see for them or it makes them
really uncomfortable or
you know maybe it's not going to work
out right so really
i agree
make it work out ladies sophie and i
have a lot of single girls for y'all let
me tell you
really i think we're better at setting
people up and setting ourselves up yeah
i set you up i think actually no gabby
set you up
oh i was oh never mind maybe i shouldn't
no i say
how many times though i've sat on this
side of this room and there have been
men that have sat on that couch saying
the same thing about sophia and i'll
just sit here twitter
thanks
it's all right
[Applause]
make her blush no what everybody die
already there's enough foundations no i
just okay i've i've messaged you a
couple times ghosted no did i really i
followed her on instagram
no follow back you don't fall like dang
she's like she's hard she's tough she's
a tough nut to crack
no i'll be honest i'll be honest it's
not you it's actually me and i would i
say that
i know but really but really anyone that
knows me knows it's actually me call her
out call her out
you have to do it on wax we got it yeah
you gotta keep it on wax you know what
i'm loving this little spark we're gonna
continue this off camera but joseph
thank you so much there's actually a
really embarrassing story all right i
finished the show i don't know if you
remember but so again the christmas
party the last christmas party the
infamous party the infamous party so you
guys did your whole thing with the with
the pajamas and everything yeah i need
that picture by the way that's how i
will send you that i've never seen that
what did i do no it's what i did so your
mom owe it your mom's the best yeah i
love your mom she's so she's so sweet
and she's like giving the presents out
and she's like oh take this blanket and
i'm like
blank it's always for i always use those
things i have them no i do too they're
so soft eight different blankets they're
insane so i have this blanket and then
you know i'm saying
bye to your mom you come and say bye and
then you come and say bye i'm like okay
i have to just be like a hundred percent
honest i would like the liquid courage
was just flowing like crazy in your
veins oh my gosh i completely forgot
about this other note
oh my uber was taking 20 minutes so
sophia was like
i i'm just going to call you one and i
got there in like five minutes oh yeah
i'm good at that stuff yeah you you're
just like all right i'm calling you uber
and then it was i felt like is she just
like trying to get me out of here as
soon as possible but anyways
so the liquid courage was flowing and
i'm like about to leave and i'm like i
just have to be so honest with you i
have the fattest crush on you
you remember this yes
i was i was so embarrassed because
i was extra embarrassed
because
i think you and your mom were like
standing right there i was like oh gosh
like why am i doing this
wait wait i got an idea
what did she say i don't even know what
i said do you remember what's up
thank you
no
today oh no sophia probably said your
uber's
here that was i mean at least nice no
you were so nice you were super nice
about it but then you yeah you were like
all right
your uber's here
i was like
yeah savage on christmas eve
my god
oh my god
okay i just hate like beating around the
bush i'm just like i'm too
say straight up well i think it's better
to be straight up about something that
you like want or like and why i mean
because if it works out then it works
out yeah you know because if you don't
say anything some people are gonna be
like oh my gosh i hate the games i hate
the game i love the game and sophia
loves oh i'm sure you love the games i'm
sure you love it i hate the the oh i i
can't text them until they text me first
and then like that's not true
a liar
[Applause]
all right is that anyone else fixing or
is it just me
it's pretty warm that was intense but um
i wanted to thank you so much for coming
on the show today you are awesome and
you're such a good podcaster yeah you're
so successful just plug where everyone
can find your social media all your
movies coming out your podcast
everything yeah wait do i just say it
yeah go crazy yeah well instagram is at
projo too
uh i actually don't know my handles for
anything else well your podcast is do
you have opposite ends uh
um instagram yeah at opposite ends um
trying to think watch out for lava
that's coming out um there we go the
chariot and
bunker 13. let's
get it if you want to see him shirtless
on a horse like we all do make sure you
check that movie out thank you again so
much for coming on thank you thank you
guys for tuning in this week to unwaxed
we will see you next
tuesday bye y'all
[Music]
you